so it's finally happening I'm starting a
podcast it's gonna be called good for
you we need to decide the song she
decide the art we're going to use she
looks like she's gonna slash my tires
put on the walls nothing funnier to me
than a fat like I want to kill you but a
lot of goes into making a podcast
studio I thought it was gonna be like
super easy it's goddamn nightmare ahead
men in my house for like three weeks
that I don't know which hasn't happened
since I was at college odd and I have to
pay that so we need to pick a wall paper
but fabric is fabric walls and a punk
ass studio help with the sound well this
you know it's gonna cute though it's
like a little bit like the walls of the
restaurant you cheat on your spouse with
club in Japan or you do things that
shouldn't end up on YouTube at all
tiny cheetahs did you cut this up
shirts ha ha I want to have a podcast
but my only stipulation was we have to
do it in my house so that I don't have
to go anywhere
there's shuffle down the hall that's
called modern feminism
[Music]
I mean at least rug met whoa yes baby
where do you think the camera fell in
the conv you're gonna be the closet kind
of set are you gonna be like Whitney
keeps us in a closet yeah is this gonna
end up baby be part of this story wall
upholstery curtain fabric we need to
discuss a rug I want the vibe to be like
the label millionaire I love animal
print but I don't want it to feel like
gold-digging miniskirt oh I like
this monkeys and elephants
yes name okay yeah Swift on here with
this you're gonna get me what if we get
denim just denim and then like a
contrast color I love I feel like you're
a denim good how dare you picking a
theme song when you ask someone to make
a song for a girls anything it's always
like sassy and sexy and like whoo it's
based on this show from the 70s called
Whitney in the robot
[Music]
this was a real show
okay we picked one Nathan you want to
weigh in on these pictures podcasts
these are to gap gap Old Navy
Old Navy it needs to sit like fun a
comedy podcasts the turtlenecks very
serious I feel like you're talking about
like the economy that would not be
happening Carol no it's - Lauren Hutton
boom bra floor of it I know but it no
that's just serious eyes the gay
audience how dare you
what is that do I have a goiter I'm not
joking it's a farm or did we just
discover a goiter guys call the doctor
no what is that
time has run out literally and
figuratively the computer is dead that's
how long we've been working on this I
[Music]
murdered
[Applause]